permeating the ocean in every direction
is a mystery that has haunted scientists
for decades a mystery that began as
tensions between the US and the Soviet
Union were coming to a boiling point
during the Cold War different branches
of the American Military set up stations
around the world to monitor Soviet
activity including in the deep ocean
sosus a classified network of passive
sonar devices deployed throughout the
Atlantic and Pacific Oceans had a very
specific goal in mind to detect Soviet
submarines but when the Cold War fizzled
out in 1990 the Navy decided to change
gears it offered scientists at NOAA the
opportunity to use their sonar arrays in
the Pacific to monitor environmental
conditions it would give researchers the
ability to monitor volcanic activity in
the Pacific Northwest and study
hydrothermal systems by 1991 NOAA was
fully integrated into the system and
began recording data but as soon as they
started listening they started hearing a
strange
sound the repeating pulses sound almost
like an underwater car alarm or maybe a
creature calling out or some strange
geologic process that we don't
understand the noise is so loud that it
can be recorded throughout the Pacific
and more than 30 years later it still
hasn't stopped it was named upsweep but
maybe sound from hell would have been
more fitting and as spooky as this was
it was only the start of the strange
sounds the scientists recorded next came
the
whistle
and
Julia and the loudest sound of all came
to be known as the
bloop this sound was picked up by
hydrophones placed more than 3,000 km
apart what was going on in the ocean
were the scientists picking up
clandestine military exercises giant
squid doing something weird undiscovered
sea monsters it turns out the ocean is
much much noisier than we'd ever guessed
as more research stations have placed
hydrophones across the oceans we've
gotten better at identifying certain
things but there is still so much we
still can't identify why does the ocean
have so many strange sounds and why have
scientists managed to guess at the
origins of certain sounds While others
remain and utter
mystery at its most basic level sound is
compressed energy a vibrating wave it
requires a substance to travel through
whether that's solid liquid or gas like
the iconic tagline for the movie Alien
says in space no one can hear you scream
that's because space is a vacuum with an
extremely low density of particles
available for sound to vibrate through
given the importance of particles in
carrying sound it's probably no surprise
that noise travels different above water
and Below water molecules are much more
tightly packed than gases making the
ocean about 800 times denser than air so
when a sound wave vibrates a molecule of
water the vibration gets passed on much
faster to the next molecule than when
sound moves through air in fact sound
travels almost five times faster in
water than in air but the distance that
sound travels in water relies on more
than just speed and that that's where
things get complicated the physical and
chemical properties of the ocean all
contribute to how sound waves move
temperature salinity and pressure all
play a role near the ocean surface is
the lowest pressure but the highest
temperature and the high temperature
causes sound to move faster in the
deepest parts of the ocean is the
coldest temperature but the highest
pressure and in that case the high
pressure is what causes sound to move
faster but between between a few hundred
and 1,000 m is a zone of low temperature
and relatively low pressure where the
speed of sound is minimal a sound wave
in this channel will naturally radiate
in all directions but when it travels
into shallower or deeper water outside
of the channel it encounters an area
with faster sound transmission and when
the sound waves encounter this the waves
tend to be refracted or bent back
towards the region of lower Speed
without losing much energy energy this
means that sounds tend to stay in this
channel traveling slowly over great
distances this zone is known as the soar
Channel or the Deep sound channel it
preserves sound so well that in an
experiment from 1960 the sound of
explosives detonated in the waters off
the coast of Australia were heard all
the way in Bermuda nearly 20,000 km away
thanks to the soar Channel scientists
can monitor everything from underwater
volcanoes to earthquakes and as
scientists have learned about the way
sound moves in the ocean they've been
able to listen in more and more they've
placed hydrophones and other passive
recording systems all around the world
and it turns out the ocean is a very
noisy
place as of the most recent surveys
there are 26 Marine Mammal species
around 35,000 known fish species and
nearly
250,000 Marine invertebrates and a lot
of these creatures are soniferous or
sound producing we didn't even always
know that whales could sing but today we
know that all Marine Mammal species make
sounds either echolocation for hunting
or sounds for communication in fact
certain baling whales communicate at
frequencies that are specifically Suited
to so far allowing them to stay in touch
over long distances while migrating but
in at least one case the satation
communication seemed to go wrong in 1989
researchers picked up calls from the
North Pacific that sounded like a blue
or fin whale but instead of being in the
normal 15 to 25 Hertz range this whale
was calling at 52 Hertz a much higher
frequency nicknamed 52 the cation earned
earned the moniker of the loneliest
whale because scientists believed its
wrongly pitched calls might mean it had
trouble interacting with its species the
unusual whales voice continued to be
picked up for decades leading scientists
to speculate that it was a Mal formation
or maybe that the whale was some kind of
hybrid between two species that don't
normally mate it's a mystery that still
hasn't been definitively solved to this
day though some now think there may be
more than one whale communicating at
this frequency 52 might not be the
loneliest whale after all and mysterious
whales are only the start when it comes
to sea creatures making strange sounds
forget julu there are probably hundreds
of species of fish and invertebrates who
chatter away without us being able to
identify them for example it took years
for scientists to figure out that the
crackling sound that they heard near
coral reefs was made by snapping ing
shrimp whose claws produce a loud snap
when they snap them shut fast enough to
create a projectile lethal bubble they
used for hunting there are also Daily
choruses in coral reefs around the world
when the intensity of sound increases by
two to three orders of magnitude after
Sunset and just Before Sunrise
scientists don't know how many species
contribute to this sudden cacophony but
in one case they discovered that a major
contributor of the noise around New
Zealand came from Hungry sea urchins
their skeleton was acting as an
amplifier for the sound of their
chomping the ocean is chalk full of
organisms who are making noises whether
it's because of their hunting or their
feeding or just because they want to
stay in touch with friends and all of
that noise means there are a lot of
sounds we haven't identified yet but on
top of the organisms are all of the
geological processes happening
underwater and that adds adds yet
another layer of
[Music]
complication as we've talked about in
previous videos about underwater
volcanoes the sea floor is a hot bed of
geologic activity tectonic plates
spreading apart or subducting under each
other create magma and earthquakes and
even violent eruptions all these
geologic processes produce sounds that
can be picked up on hydrophones but
there are also massive glaciers and
icebergs in the North and South poles
and those huge slow moving structures
also create noise in fact they're now
thought to be responsible for multiple
noises that were previously
unidentified remember the bloop the
loudest ocean sound that's ever been
recorded researchers heard it in 1997 on
hydrophones scattered across the Pacific
they were trying to listen to underwater
volcanic activity and this noise was
nothing like the sound sounds they'd
been hearing for years theories abounded
maybe it was a secret military exercise
maybe it was a giant squid maybe it was
a really really loud whale or it could
be an Undiscovered deepsea creature then
in 2005 researchers put hydrophones
closer to Antarctica and captured the
bizarre noise again it was an Ice Quake
the incredibly loud sound of an iceberg
cracking and breaking away from the
Antarctic glacier
the more scientists listened to the
movement of ice the more they realized
it explained other mysterious sounds too
the noise Julia is now thought to have
been a large Iceberg running around its
bottom slowly scraped Away by the sea
floor but even as researchers have
expanded their acoustic arrays certain
sounds have remained a mystery that's
the case for upsweep the repeated
lifting noise that scientists have been
hearing around the Pacific for more than
30 30 years although it's getting
quieter the sound can still be heard and
even weirder it fluctuates seasonally
its intensity peaking in the spring and
fall the origin point of the sound is
thought to be in an area of volcanic
activity but we still don't know what it
is it's yet another mystery of the deep
ocean one that we may never
solve despite all the things we don't
know yet about underwater sounds there
are a few key things we're becoming more
and more aware of first a lot of
organisms like living in noisy
neighborhoods when researchers played
recordings of healthier reefs around
reefs that had been degraded 50% more
fish ended up repopulating the degraded
reefs than those without any recordings
the same preferences are true of coral
Lara who spend an initial life phase
away from the reefs before settl in back
into them to grow into Coral structures
research like this seems to prove that
noise plays a crucial role in these
Coastal communities but the other thing
researchers have proved is that humans
are increasingly contributing to ocean
noises and we do not make the kind of
noise that aquatic species appreciate
motorboat noise around reefs has a
negative impact on fish reproduction and
shipping traffic definitely causes
issues for whales who hunt and
communicate using frequencies that are
similar to the noises the ships make
what's more climate change is driving
increasingly high temperatures in the
ocean and that heating means that sounds
will travel differently which could
create yet another problem for species
that use sound to hunt and communicate
so while the oceans might be naturally
noisy places humans are changing the
kinds of noise pretty drastically and
that means it can be sometimes even
harder to figure out out the source of
mysterious sounds but the more we listen
the more we find and the better we
understand the way that sound
contributes to the well-being of aquatic
organisms so scientists will keep Eaves
dropping on fishes and volcanoes and
icebergs in hopes that we figure out
what all is going on in that vast watery
expanse whenever there's a big mystery
like these mysterious ocean sounds or
even like recent UFO sightings the first
thing everyone does is run to the
scientists for answers everyone loves to
speculate but it's usually physics and
math that have the answers some might
say that trying to actually do science
on these Mysteries ruins the fun but I
disagree what's more satisfying than
finding the answer to a puzzle that has
had everyone stumped for years and what
is Earth if not a big Rock full of
mysteries and what is science if not the
way we solve those Mysteries with the
tools of physics and math under your
belt anyone can be a real life mystery
solver and surprisingly there's a free
and easy way to practice these skills
brilliant has so many courses on
subjects that reveal the physics of the
real world and get you thinking about
the phenomena we all experience but may
not understand brilliant is the best way
to learn math data science and computer
science interactively I've always
struggled with lectures and textbooks
but Brilliance is an interactive Lear
learning environment where lessons are
structured around things that feel more
like games and puzzles than like college
coursework there are levers slides and
buttons so you can test theories and
visualize highlevel Math and Science
Concepts the physics of the everyday
course has been particularly helpful in
visualizing Concepts that I see all the
time but never fully understood it helps
you investigate things like household
objects buildings Bridges and weather
patterns unraveling the Mysteries of the
everyday maybe the way toilets work
isn't mysterious to everyone but it was
to me and even if you do know how
toilets work I guarantee there is
something in this 38p part lesson that
will surprise you brilliant has
thousands of lessons like this from
foundational to advanced math to AI data
science neural networks and more with
new lessons added monthly so to better
learn how to confidently navigate this
world of overwhelming numbers and to try
everything brilliant has to offer free
for a full 30 days visit brilliant.org
sreal science or click on the link in
the description the first 200 people
will get 20% off brilliant's annual
premium subscription and every sign up
helps this
channel